foreign
we'll go back to the second day of the
workshop
um just one announcement so at 4 pm at
the end of the talks today we're
thinking of hosting an open problem
session it was like this like an
informal session where uh people can
come up the Whiteboard and list their
favorite open problems that we'd like to
have solved
um if this will happen at 4 pm today so
just be a one hour open problem session
uh
how to present a Sebastian Forester from
the University of Salzburg
you sent on craps Sebastian Forster is
an assistant professor at the University
of Salzburg he completed his PhD at the
University of Vienna in 2015 where he
was supervised by Monica hensinger and
it was then a postdoc at Max playing
Institute of harmonics and then at
University of Guiana
his main research interest is the design
of efficient graph algorithms in
particular for dynamic and distributing
models
um so I'm talking about the dynamic
algorithms for K Center for clustering
and I somewhat chose this topic because
it nicely connects to work on Dynamic
shortest path this is a topic that I
have worked a lot on and I know that
many in the audience have worked a lot
on that so I think this is
John dropped with Emilio krushani who's
a postdoc Ramos Guaranty who's around
yasami nazari who wanted to come but
couldn't because of Visa issues and
until miscarriage
so um yeah the overall motivation I
mentioned this in in this short
lightning talk yesterday was okay maybe
you know we like to do these Dynamic
algorithms and then there are people who
work on like say Network science and for
them like Dynamic is something very
natural they often have this idea of
like yeah you know we study evolving
networks and and the idea is just how
can we bring these two things a bit
closer together and yeah clustering is
like one of the natural connecting
points um I would say like you know how
could we
then do something
um that might be somewhat of interest to
people in in more like that community
and um the main point here is like I'm
talking about clustering on graphs
so
there have been Dynamic clustering
algorithms ours is not the first
um that's a well-studied problem but
these algorithms that have been studied
are some not tailored to graphs
and now you mentioned maybe that's a
good thing right maybe something more
General is actually good
um but I'll mention in or I'll explain
in a minute like why we really need like
tailored algorithms for the setting
at least for the setting that that we
have in mind
that makes sense
okay just to quickly remind you um
what's this case and the problem the K
clustering problem
my case and the clustering problem so
we're given a metric space with points
and we want to select K points as
centers that would be the cluster
centers say case three and and I would
select those three for example and now
um I I want to say okay every node
chooses
um every Point chooses the the center
that is closest to it
and joins the cluster of that Center
and now there's a natural thing that
descent these clusters have a radius
like what's the the furthest away Point
um for every cluster Center in in that
cluster and that's um the radius of the
cluster and in total we want to minimize
um the maximum radius in our clustering
okay so this is this
distance of any node to its closed
center that is what we want to to
minimize
as often these problems are somewhat
hard it's NP hard to approximate this
with an effect of two minus Epsilon so
the focus is usually on constant Factor
approximation
okay so I I mentioned before this has
been studied on Metric spaces on point
sets
um yeah so we have a set of points and
we have a metric this this function D
like a distance function on the points
just test these uh
yes so it's a typical axioms for a
metric
and in a graph the pairwise show this
path distances induce a metric with the
nose is appointed
and now my question is can we get
um Dynamic constant Factor approximation
algorithms for this case Center problem
if the metric is induced by a
dynamically changing and directed graph
so that's that's the objective
okay now let me explain shortly like
um unwrited or weighted so both instance
okay so so what's the dynamic model
um I said there are certain differences
like in Dynamic Point sets we have
insertions and deletions of points like
say we have these points and now we just
add an additional point
um
and and that's it
in Dynamic graph say we have this graph
and we insert on this additional Edge
um yeah then
there are many changes
in this metric right so here it's more
like okay we
um
extend
um the metric by this point
and the other other points are somewhat
unaffected and here it's like okay we
insert this and then you know it could
happen that like Omega n Square
um
pairs change the distance so that the
metric is changed a lot so
my intuitive view is a bit like
um here yeah the the metric is extended
or reduced by points and here it's more
like I'm actually by inserting shrinking
the metric modifying um the whole metric
in in a certain way or if I delete um an
edge I'm extending
another subtle thing is that
yeah I would assume that the distance is
not given a priori so it's the task of
the algorithm to to maintain these
distances and the metric or like the
relevant parts of it whereas here it's
usually assumed that one has query
access to um distances to this D
function the metric and and that's
somewhat natural if you consider for
example
um Point sets in an euclidean space or
something like that you just say oh you
have the coordinates and then the
distance you can just simply compute
by looking at the code
it's a natural thing to have experiences
are you also going to shrink the set of
vertices of the graph that you
potentially care about or you always
keep the same so the formal assumption
would be to keep them always the same I
mean you could
um delete all all edges of a graph and
then okay you always have to
um
then it's a bit tricky right you would
have to restart them because this one
always needs to be a center if it's not
connected to everything but yeah
maybe it would be nice to formally treat
this explicitly
okay so so the conclusion here is um we
cannot use prior work
um that has been
um
designed for dynamic Point sets in a
black box manner for the dynamic across
but still um this has been like
influential work so let me briefly
um
what is the the related work okay there
are static algorithms and there are
these classic two approximation
algorithms and on graphs with and nodes
and images you can Implement those in
time pay a lot maybe for the extra
depends on the exact setting
and um there has been very nice work
on graphs you can get rid of this fact
okay we showed how to do this with a
randomized algorithm in um and then
there's a nice recent solza paper
that shows like
how by a nice view of randomization you
can also do this in linear time with an
arguably simpler
so and and what's known for like
Dynamic Point sets the case and
non-dynamic points so
um
first was a was a result that had like a
case where up the time that also very
recently in an effort um including many
people
um
reduce this too until they're okay
update time and those works also give
two plus Epsilon approximation and then
there has been even more work on point
sets like looking at special metrics say
on a doubling Dimension or looking at um
somewhat
extended question of how do you
dynamically maintain a consistent case
and the clustering for whatever the
exact definition of consistency
okay so that's roughly Where We Are
and
now I would like to argue that a
somewhat natural goal for us would be
that you know maybe we want something
that is roughly comparable to to this
like very classic deterministic result
that has an update time of K times M so
roughly speaking this is K times the
time you need for a static single Source
shortest path computation
and so somehow the natural thing that I
would argue to to get this now we want a
fully dynamic or fully Dynamic partially
Dynamic algorithm such that the overhead
compared to an approximate signal so
this path computation is like an okay or
till they're okay
so I would argue this is like you know
the natural first goal if you want to
study this problem and yeah somehow I
set it up in such a way that they can
give you the good news and that's
exactly
um what we get so the first thing is we
have a fully Dynamic algorithm that
gives a two plus Epsilon approximation
to that problem
and it has either this update time or
this update time so it's K times this n
to the 1.5 to 9.
three depending on whether you're in an
unweighted or weighted graph
so some of you
might know what what's going on here
those are the update times
for fully Dynamic OnePlus Epsilon
approximate single Source shortest path
and for fundamental reasons those
algorithms yeah Jan is walking in right
at the right time for fundamental
reasons these algorithms internally use
fast matrix multiplication
so this has some
explanation given by conditional lower
bounds
so are there any reductions either way
showing that like
um
you can't beat the the ones up some
approximate speed times so
um only like you know
morally or intuitively I would argue
that somehow
um what what do you want right somehow I
think you do want an approximate
um distance to your cluster Center
and um but
it seems it seems hard to go to go below
that right
um
it's a bit like
yeah
so so say for example you want to give a
two approximation of the diameter right
um then essentially the best way of
doing this is run a single Source path
computation from from an Aboriginal
vertex and I would say this k equals one
case already is very similar right you
have one cluster but you somehow I guess
you want to know
um the distance to the cluster Center so
unless you change the problem to
something where you don't
um want to have this distance to the
cluster Center explicitly it sounds very
natural to me that you cannot do better
than um
about
um the question what is your request
what is the request bone here it's
yeah not really bounded like Caper
update right
um
in the decremental I would have to check
and in the incremental we have to really
explicitly work on the recourse so
basically
that the number of centers exactly
exactly exactly exactly okay would be
the trivial thing and yes
Okay so this thing is a reduction so any
single shortest path approximate single
shortest path algorithm you have
um if it works against an Adaptive
adversary you can use that
I have okay I have one question is
that you can't do better than it I don't
think so I'm not aware of it
um I think people have studied recourse
very explicitly also um maybe
I'm sorry I was actually uh but yeah I'm
not aware of it and people have studied
recourse very explicitly
request means um like how much do you
change these case centers from One
update to the other
and and here it's like we don't even try
pretty much
yeah so my other question was what kind
of assumptions do you need to make on
this OnePlus Epsilon proximate sssp does
it need to maintain the distances
exclusively or so um I'll talk about it
in a minute but let's answer it already
now so it has to be against an Adaptive
adversary and it needs to maintain
um the distances you need to be able to
like vary the distance in whatever small
time
yeah I mean you know if you have like
you know something like you do single
Source through this path and you have
like super linear time then in the same
time you can just like query like the
distance to the to the source for
everything
but like while we're at it like
something that's interesting I think is
you do need um that it works against an
Adaptive adversary but in some sense you
only need these approximate distances
right unless you really want to have a
path
um from the node to the center but if
you do not care about this you just want
the clustering
um then then you do not need this so
it's a nice example of like oh you need
like something that works against an
Adaptive adversary but the value version
is
good question
um so the the Dynamics sspm algorithms
these are randomized are they given
deterministic oh yeah okay so this one's
deterministic this one's randomized
against and adaptive effects
and if your external case answer
algorithm was you know if you just
wanted the result for oblivious
adversary would you be okay with uh
oblivistary SS C algorithms I don't know
how to do it because I'm doing a
reduction that's inherently adaptive
access to the base
um I guess then you should be able to
just black ones uh use the insist and
works on uh I'm not so sure right
because
um as I argued before right if you just
insert one Edge you could change
um you could change the the distance
between many pairs of nodes
um and and that's just a different model
like even if we did that like have a
distance Oracle or whatever
um and then say even if it was able to
like
help me quickly give us query access
it's a bit unclear so I I don't see how
you bring these two things together you
know
all right so that that's fully Dynamic
thing that will work via reduction
um then the results on partially Dynamic
are now particularly interesting right
because
yeah somehow
it's a natural goal to to have something
like this but single Source road is
passed in the fully Dynamic setting just
stands here that's that's just something
we cannot really
um we cannot really avoid here
um so similar to signals or throw this
paths now is the question like what
could you do in the partially Dynamic
setting and in
the decremental setting with Edge
deletions and we get an overhead of
okay so the other update time is K to
the K times m to the little one so again
that's in line with what we have for
approximate single sources
One update time
and then in the incremental setting like
we have Edge insertions we also get this
but there
um it's actually a bit challenging and I
will tell you later why and we get a
four plus Epsom approximation not the
two plus Epsilon for exhibition
and we really need to exploit oblivious
randomization here yes this decremental
one that you can make determinists
using powerful
approximate signals of shortest paths
okay so now uh this this reduction
that's um I think nice and easy
um
here again a reminder how does this
one type of two approximation work it's
this algorithm that starts with an
arbitrary first notice the center say
this one and then just takes the node
that has the maximum distance
um to the center and says okay that's my
setting sensor and then you go on you
find the node that maximizes the
distance to these two nodes
simultaneously
say it's this one and this will be the
third center right this is this is the
series description approximation
and it's somehow not sensitive to the
distances being exact if you only have
like one plus Epsilon approximations so
this distance this will give you two
plus Epsom approximation
good thing
okay now that the reductions as follows
um we want to simulate this algorithm
using a single shortest path algorithm
so to this graph I add some artificial
supersource that's outside of the graph
and I start now maintaining single
Source distances from this node and
initially
it's not connected to anything but the
algorithm internally has to do something
already somehow has to prepare for Stuff
and now after every update to the graph
for the loop well first I forward this
deletion or insertion the update to to
that graph this approximate single
Source through this path data structure
does something internally and then I
start simulating now this Gonzalez
algorithm so after every update there's
a new simulation
um I just say okay
take an arbitrary first center say this
one C1
and connect it to the Super Source test
and now I want to find the notes node
that's furthest away from from C1 and
that's that I can do by finding the
nodes that's furthest away from this
node s
it's also connected to a Super Source
again now I find the like node that's
furthest away from s and that's just the
same as saying I want to find the node
that's furthest away from from these two
pages is A plus two systematic a plus
one systematic overestimate so I can use
the distance to the Super Source as the
proxy of the distance to the city okay
and when I'm done like these are my
centers and then
uh it's a fully Dynamic algorithm I just
remove these edges again deletions so
I'm done and
the important thing here is this is
highly like adaptive the algorithm needs
to work against them otherwise this
already doesn't work
okay so the update time it's a reduction
at o of K times whatever the update time
for my approximate single Source
distances yes
okay questions
okay so somehow this is
good news this is nice but maybe on the
other hand it's
not so deep so
it's somehow Justified I guess both in
terms of like techniques and in terms of
like getting the fastest possible
running time for for different settings
to now look at partially Dynamic
algorithms
okay and now
these are if you know the clustering
literature a bit these are now based on
um this other type of two approximate
heuristic
um that's based on our independent cells
um
it's a bit like it makes it
um so what's in our independent set it's
it's a set of nodes
such that any pair in in the set has
distance more than R yeah independent
set would be like
distances must be more than one they are
not neighboring and you can generate
again
look at this notion of maximality like
such an our independent set this maximal
if it cannot be extended without
correlating
okay
so how could you compute the maximal our
independent set yeah for example by this
standard greedy algorithm
um you start with some first note as
being part of your our independence set
then check what are the notes that are
within this radius R from that node
um you take them away from the graph
start with some arbitrary second note
now as a node linear or independent set
to again this thing
um take it or all of them the term
distance are away and so on okay and
that picture suggests already somehow
yeah you want to in the end use these
are independent sets as your clusters
you just need to find like what's a good
radius for doing that and and you need
to argue why is that in a good
approximation 2K
um we'll often
um talk about something
that called K bounded maximal or
independent set what I mean by that if I
say that is well
if the set size less than k then it is a
maximal our independent set or if it has
size k
um yeah then it could be one or it could
be not but somehow conceptually it just
means I'm not extending this computation
any further
um I just want to know do I have a
maximum or independent set of size
um almost K or not in in many cases
yeah and that's relevant I'm writing K
bounded maximal our independence
okay and and this heuristic this two
approximation is essentially just saying
yeah find the smallest value of R that's
possible such that the maximum our
independent set has size at most K now
if it has size at most K you can use it
as a solution for K Center and if you
find the uh the smallest touch value
then you get a true approximation
so the algorithm is is roughly like that
um here you guess you are either by
doing an outer binary research or like
doing this for like powers of of OnePlus
Epsilon and then you compute the maximal
our independent set Say by this greedy
algorithm
um and if you have more than k
um notes in this our independent set
then and somehow you you cannot cover
the whole graph like
um with any arbitrary our independent
set so you you want to increase your R
um if you have less than K nodes you
want to try to decrease the r
um until you yeah by the search fine
find the right
is it the monotone function because it's
Computing maximal right yeah it's a bit
like um
subtly
um depending on on the choice of like
you know you know the permutation of how
you um
yeah you don't you don't really need to
like um yeah for example this this
powers of one is absolutely just do it
for all powers and
it's good like like for like at least
for us we do understand so we do not
need to um deal with this right now
oh
okay and again right here
prices if I compute like this K bounded
maximum our independent set and check if
it's indeed maximal I don't have to like
do this whole our independent set
computation
um that just um sometimes relevant in
terms of
um running
okay and um yeah the nice Lemma is if I
chose my R big enough
um so opt is like what's the minimum
radius I can get from an optimal case
Center solution then every maximal our
independent set size of most case so I
have to guarantee that that I will be
successful okay that's
um the Black Box thing we use from
priority
okay and again if we have one plus
Epsilon approximate distances we get the
two plus steps
okay
now um I'd first like to tell you how we
designed the the decremental algorithm
um so if the graphs undergoing deletions
that's
somewhat
um I would say
um yeah in line with how other designs
um work for like similar problems so
distances are not decreasing over time
um yeah you delete something then nodes
cannot get closer together they can only
increase the distance so if you have an
R independent set it will always
continue to be in our independent set
the only thing is maybe you know maybe
before it covered the whole graph and
then some distances increase and then it
doesn't cover the whole graph anymore
but
um the the parts you have from your our
independent set they don't go bad that's
the heavy thing you can exploit here so
the scheme is like you know you have a
guess of r that somehow increases over
time
and for your current guest of hour you
increase the number of centers you have
also over time right here first you try
to do it maybe with k equals one Center
then maybe two three until at some point
maybe K Centers do not suffice anymore
and then you need to increase your guess
so far
okay
and how we do it similar to this
reduction before we maintain
um decremental approximate signals or
shortest path from some kind of Super
Source that's connected to every Center
that you currently chose
and after each deletion if you update
this single Source shoulders path data
structure and if some node is not
covered anymore if the distance
um is more than one perception out to
any Center
um then you check right if you exceeded
your budget if you already have case
centers that you chose
um yeah then your guess of R is not good
enough anymore you need to increase it
and the next phase of the algorithm
otherwise
you can now you know similar to that
greedy algorithm I showed you before
simply add this node V to your current
centers and restart the decremental
single Solace path algorithm right
connected to the Super Source you're
more connected to the Super Source and
connect it
okay so um just want to
show you a picture from what I said sure
So say these are the current clusters of
mine things the shortest path type of
things if I delete something then what
could happen yeah this node could
somehow have to leave
um this this cluster from from that RM
dependent set and it has to like start
its own thing
that's that's what we do in such a case
okay so what's What's the total update
time
the main questions how often do we need
to start
um single shortest paths so this is like
um
total update time here so I I can only
think of like you know
in these singles or shortest path data
structures I can only tell you okay
what's um the time
um for for running them like
until everything's deleted it doesn't
matter how many conditions
that's why this doesn't depend on on the
number of deletions and so the update
time is roughly like this like
um
for each guess of hour that I make for
each scale this set C increases at most
K times because I'm looking at Key
Center
um so this decremental signal so sure
this path algorithm
is restarted K times the logarithmic
value times here
this Lambda is is this aspect ratio of
the graph in an unweighted graph I would
do log n here because the maximum
distance is M like the distance
increases almost 1 to n
um if you have a weighted graph then
somehow you need to think of what's the
maximum
distance you can increase it's a
logarithmic number of of times times K
that you need to restart
please so that's the scheme for for the
decremental algorithm
okay and um
that's somehow nice but the real
problems um
omitted this yeah you can do this
randomized auditorialistically
um
so
now we somehow like to use the same
scheme right and say okay yeah I insert
stuff
um so distances
never increase
um things only become closer
um can you do the same can they exploit
this and yet to some extent write this
this whole idea of you have the scale
and it reduces that that still works
like
uh I was just confused in the last about
the update time sure do you need to like
query the data structure in every single
vertex uh yeah that's that's one of the
details that I've omitted right um so
this data structure
it tells you explicitly when uh the
distance estimate of a node increases
increases okay and that works because
it's a one plus Epsilon approximation so
you don't have a recourse problem
because for every node it can only
increase like in OnePlus Epsilon steps a
logarithm number of times
yeah that's one of these details that
are somewhat a bit standard that I
forget
okay so incremental we would somehow
like to use a similar scheme but the
problem is an R independent set will not
necessarily continue being an RNA and
the most extreme thing is like say you
have this R independent set and you just
insert an edge between the two centers
right
so then of course right these two nodes
are not independent anymore
so there could be conflicts after
insertions
and then that means we somehow need to
update or recompute our set C our
independent set because we want the
number of centers to be at most okay
right
if you don't do this then somehow
um we might have things that are
overlapping in the whole
um correctness proof doesn't go through
so we need to do something
um but why is it non-trivial not to do
something for every node in this our
independent set we maintain approximate
signals of shortest paths
now changing C is is therefore expensive
because
every time we put something in C we pay
like at least a linear or M to the one
plus Little One update time we cannot
bond this any better right just to
initialize it we need linear time
so the total update time will be the
number of nodes ever contained in the
set c times
I think so I want to keep this small
this is like the recourse and it's the
Total Recall
how much changes do I make to see over
the whole update sequence that's what I
want to keep small
so I want to maintain our independent
set
with no total recalls
okay and
um to analyze this um this in this
attorney at all paper
um there's a nice view on it
um I think it's original to that paper
so at least we've learned a lot from
that
um so now conceptually think of doing
what's called this our neighborhood
graph
so that's just like for every node
um and just connect every node to every
other node that's in distance R of it
like this
you can do that for the whole graph and
then an independent set in this
neighborhood graph gr that's just our
independent set in the original graph
okay so now I'm asking just a very basic
question about the total recourse of
maximal independent set which is a
well-studied problem in dynamica
okay one thing here like I'm not
constructing this neighborhood graph in
the algorithm it's more of an analysis
tool
um and all of that I really do is
a a compute K bounded maximal
independent sets on this neighborhood
graph and for doing that I partially
construct it but only to the extent that
is necessary
and for for those that are really into
the details here
it's actually not so easy as you notice
here I'm using exact distances you would
have to do this for approximate
distances if you want to be formally
clean it's a bit tricky
um but just to say to say it completely
it's also not necessary it's just an
analysis thing you could directly
analyze it with this without this
neighborhood
okay so we want to maintain um this K
bounded maximal independent set in the
neighborhood graph and we want a total
recourse that's polynomial in k
ideally something like till they're okay
and since the input graph is incremental
this neighborhood graph is also
incremental and yeah but what bound can
I give right even if my input graph is
it sparse this could be dense and I
could have up to say n Square insertions
here
and
so the best of our understanding we do
not see how the Mis algorithms that are
known provide
um a good bound on the total recourse
they are known to have like
um I think even constant records per
update
but now you cannot just say Okay overall
you have like M update and and somehow
um stating it the way I did here is a
bit oversimplifying right because now
I'm not exploiting that I want a k
bounded Mis and not like
and yeah we
we didn't find a way of of doing it with
an Mis
um
uh I'm not sure about the records
I'm not sure about the records of the
Mis algorithms
like you don't
like
but I mean they have poly logarithmic
update time so that Tripoli bounce the
request no because
so the paper of chechik and Zhang and
also uh of soil and others they are
using multiple copies
I see I see but you don't need a worst
responsive right if you want yeah if you
want both case no no we did no no
definitely not a worst response so this
is um an amortized bound here
because um also the single Source
shortest path approximates okay it's
actually two yeah yeah that's uh it
shouldn't have a tilde here right um
it's it's a constant yeah yeah but yeah
um
okay so we came up with something else
um that's um more like
um we
we want to have a dominating set on this
neighborhood graph
and that dominating such as small total
recourse until they're okay
and then we maintain a k bounded maximal
independent set on the dominating set
or on the subgroup like say this is the
dominating set then here's the subgraph
induced by the dominating set on the
neighborhood graph
and then we maintain an Mis on that
okay and in that way
we can guarantee that every node is at a
distance of most two to a center in this
mis
um in in the neighborhood graph so in
the real graph in distance at most 2R to
a center so that's why it gives in total
of four plus Epsilon approximation
okay
and now I just quickly sketch um how to
do this so
um
there's a sampling algorithm
um of course right you cannot just have
a dominating set that that small always
there's one catch here
um so we do random sampling we sample
klog and nodes uniformly at random then
remove the sample nodes and the
neighbors from the graph and
if now I have more than n half nodes
left then we can say there isn't an Mis
of size at most k
that scale is not good for us so that's
the that's the catch here that's where
we use something problem specific and
for this clustering problem then we
would in our algorithm move to the next
scale otherwise if we have only n half
nodes F we just iterate
okay and I'm skipping this proof but if
I reduce of course uh like the size you
always buy in half then I only have a
logarithmic number of such stages and it
does work because of
because if I can stop in that case if
there's no Mis
so
um this is a static algorithm the
incremental algorithm is is very similar
so almost the same analysis would work
then and here the important thing is
this algorithm that works with sampling
and reduces uh removes the neighbors of
the sample node from the graphs that
only needs access to the edges incident
on that set s in gr and because for
those nodes in in the set S I will have
do a single so slow as path computation
I know somehow what the Neighbors in the
neighborhood graph will be and that's
why I partially construct the
neighborhood graph and it just works
within the running time
so I think we can skip that proof like
why if I have more than n half nodes I I
don't find a small Mis
um that's standard hitting set stuff you
can
discover this and and so it remains open
like could I really maintain a k bounded
Mis with
um polynomial total recourse um that
would be nice
I'm skipping that also a bit that would
be nice because then I could maybe get
this tubular Epsilon approximation
um I somehow have this intuition that
even if it worked maybe this would like
be more like a k Square recourse and um
introduce another factor of K in the
running time and and the reason roughly
is like if you would do random
insertions and that's what like this
case where would be what you would get
for the total recourse and the intuition
is maybe you cannot do better than
random insertions if you have an
algorithm against an oblivious stats so
if you'd like to talk about this this is
like the interesting
problem from that particular thing there
okay let me conclude um so I think this
is a nice application of dynamic
approximate shortest path brings a lot
of things together that have been
developed um over the past years in that
area
and one thing I also mentioned maybe
path reporting actually seems a bit less
relevant in that context unless you
really want to find the path to the
center if you just want to Cluster the
distance is seem fine enough
um incremental was somehow the difficult
question for this problem because it's
somehow
yeah I had this Mis question that was
somehow somehow in there right and I
think that's that's somewhat really what
was interesting for me to see at least
that you have this single Souls shortest
path component and the Mis component and
it somehow goes together
one thing I want to say is maybe as a
community I I'd make these points
several times maybe incremental model is
actually sometimes more relevant than
than we consider yeah you usually have
this like feeling oh you know
decremental is the hard thing and all
the techniques just transfer to
incremental so it's definitely not the
case here as with mis as well and
incremental is maybe a bit more natural
than say decremental because yeah you
have this thing like social networks
where it's more likely that you make
friends and the graph gets more
connected and you can move pressure
Wikipedia links
um no core authorship graphs is a even
better example right you make new
courses but you really Lose chords right
so
so this type of social network analysis
I think incremental shouldn't be
underestimated
so future work for us um will definitely
work more on on other clustering
objectives in graphs um instead of
Concepts and it would be interesting now
I think to engineer
and dynamic approximate single Source
shortest path
um algorithms because I I think somehow
the rest of that algorithm that I
presented here that's somewhat
um very friendly to implementations that
sequence of shortest path is not but if
you had a you know nicely engineered
black box maybe you could then plug it
into
um
okay thanks for your attention
[Applause]
thanks so much great talk any questions
is there something known about a
conditional lower bounds so like I had
in this earlier paper with Saga I had a
conditional lower Bound for four minus
Epsilon approximate k-means for example
so there are lower bounds in before
yes yes yes yes yes I I'm really not
very familiar with it I must say and um
I guess I I would like maybe we can talk
right like the question for me is like
through these lower bounds definitely
transfer to dynamic graphs so is there
is there some you know technical detail
while they don't directly transition
that's something I think um we should
look at
the follow-up that question
um is there any hope of improving the
cons the recourse or the update time to
below okay like constant irrespective
okay
um so okay so it's it's a bit connected
to whether maybe this say k times n
lower bound applies or not right which
which I don't know
um otherwise yeah I mean you know it
could be done in the static setting so
maybe there's there's hope to do it in
the dynamic setting as well but somehow
um yeah unclear like I would say even in
the static setting it's a potential
so all the settings have somehow still
the justification
just since you mentioned my old paper
um
so the general result there was that for
both K Center k-means facility location
you could solve any of these problems
with a poly logarithmic number of single
soul shortest past competition
essentially spending the same time to
evaluate it instance
I'm just wondering since this approach
was so General uh and it does certain
kind of updates to code these things
resources possibly exactly these things
and just bloggering in something more do
you know because it isn't what I did
I don't know
but just yeah I I think that's that's
just stuff I need to leave open for the
future right now but um yeah I mean it's
very nice to have a generic result
so if you want worse approximation what
is the best known update time
I don't I don't think anything is really
known
it's just like you know
like okay worst single socialist path
right like worse approximation we don't
really have so it's a bit the question
like how do you want to beat like just
um the single Source Rhodes Pastime um
maybe getting rid of the fact okay with
a really worse approximation maybe
that's not hopeless but I can only
speculate
foreign
so in some sense a facility location
problem is nicer to work with because
you don't have this weird pound K which
really hurts you right really matters a
lot yeah your key plus one and
everything is smaller so continuous to
make the facility location is the
license
yeah yeah that's a good suggestion
thanks uh this is about the worst
approximation so about five years ago we
had this paper with Monica and Nicole
and others and we consider the one
Center problem so the diameter and
radius or radius in graphs and we looked
at the dynamic version
um we got like with basically whatever
the static algorithms were three halves
approximation with m r 10 time they
became
um we got a reduction basically a
similar in a similar way to the dynamic
single social distress problem
approximate and again the incremental
case was harder it was only oblivious
the decremental could make it adaptive
the same story happened there and I'm
curious what happens for case Center if
you also is there a similar notion of a
three-halves approximation is in one
Center or no
in the static setting
no nothing I don't yeah I mean it's
I don't know if it's what's the k for
which it becomes NPR I think it should
be
even for constantly like three
yeah definitely three yeah
okay but thanks thanks for the comment
Virginia so you called it one sentence
a quick question so suppose you have a
distance Oracle and that comes for free
it takes constant time does all these
results just imply that you get order
key update time in that setting
I don't I don't think it's clear right
because
it's not like you insert a point and
yeah because even if you inserted a
point that point could be used by others
to get a smaller distance so
you would have to like
um yeah okay so what I'm asking is if
your update time is measured just by the
number of calls you are making to a
distance or a class
then is it still open to get an order
key update time
under age updates for this problem Oh
you mean a clean over okay
poly log I mean ignore poly lock
s distances
out I think foreign
what's up
saying yeah everything's for free
times and then I think
could be possible I'm not sure I'm not
sure
I'll go through again
okay thanks
for questions
[Applause]
all right um so we'll be back